[Music]
well this is the press preview a first
look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive and we'll chat through
those front pages with consultant editor
of the daily mail andrew pearce
and deputy online editor at the new
statesman rachel kunliff they'll be
with us right through until midnight
good to see you both before we have a
chat let's just run through
the front pages for you and with the
headline
doubly jably it's great isn't it the
metro reacts to the news that from
august the 16th
not only will anyone who's been double
vaccinated be exempt from being pinged
by the nhs app but also
eu and u.s citizens who've had both jabs
can enter england without restrictions
in response to those stories the mail
declares britain's back in business
the express also focuses on the lifting
of those restrictions on travel with a
headline welcome back britain opens up
for business the telegraph says
that following on from the dispensation
for american travelers
the government is asking washington to
do the same for britons
and schaffeneck says the star
with word that northern accents could
soon die
out nonsense oh absolute
godswell up there let's talk to andrew
pearce and rachel connell if i'm
absolutely appalled at the idea that
northern accents might die out because
then i won't be able to talk to any of
my family
andrew let's start with the mail and
britain being back in business
we love your accent steve thank you
and it's a great front page for the mail
and we had a pretty positive front page
today when we said
an incredibly senior minister in the
cabinet had said
covet is now on the back foot uh
it could be virtually in full-time
retreat by october
so today the logical next step the
government has announced that
visitors who've been double jabbed from
the united states
eu can come to britain without any
quarantine restrictions
from monday france doesn't apply which
screws my holiday plans uh but uh so
france doesn't apply because that is
still
on the amber uh plus list so uh still
but we're getting
going to get a statement on france spain
and the traffic lights this
end of next week but this is a hugely
important step for
the travel industry which has been on
its knees and also we forget
how important tourism is to the british
economy
inward tourism the west end of london
the theaters which have been dark for
15 months they won't survive without
tourists coming back that's the same in
places like bath edinburgh
up and down the land so it's a hugely
important step
and it's a sign that finally we're
getting a real dividend now
from the success of the covid vaccine
rollout what is it now 81
of adults have had um have been have
been jabbed 71
have been double jab it's a tremendous
success well done the nhs
i know they've got a lot wrong the
government but they've got this vaccine
rollout done
really really well and to the doomsayers
like professor ferguson
who was behind a lot of the lockdown
rules wasn't he saying when boris
lifted the last wave of restrictions
that infections would shoot up to
200 000 a day well um they've dropped
for seven days running a slight increase
yesterday but um we're going in the
right direction
rachel what do you make of it all i mean
the express has got a similar sort of
jubilant headline
i am i i suffer from anxiety and so i
struggle to be
quite as as optimistic perhaps as those
front pages suggest
but i am certainly hopeful seeing the
the rate at which cases have fallen over
the past seven days yes a slight
increase today but still
a 36 drop on last week at the time when
as andrew said
we were expecting or we were led to
expect cases going
up and up and up um and i think it's
quite interesting that there's still
uh uncertainty among scientists about
what it is exactly that that has brought
cases down
is it a result of uh the vaccine roller
almost certainly
is it a result of the increased
transmission
during the euros which obviously we've
now seen the peak from that
possibly and again i find that quite
heartening as well just remembering that
scientists don't necessarily always have
all of the answers and therefore when we
get those worst case scenario figures
yes we should take them very seriously
and obviously we should do everything
that we can
to prevent those situations happening
but also that that's not set in stone
there is uncertainty and it may
not be as bad as expected which is what
we're seeing now
in terms of opening up in terms of
allowing
passengers from europe and the us if
they're double backs to come here
i think that leading the way on that
reopening of borders for a global hub
like britain
is very important the concerns i have
would be the concerns which some
officials have
uh as well which are that some uh
residents of of europe have had a
vaccine that perhaps the
the uk doesn't consider as effective as
some of the ones we've had
here and also uh certain states in the
us
are documenting keyword vaccines in a
way on paper rather than digital version
so it's possibly slightly easier to
forge but i think you're going to have
those issues
on opening up whenever it happens and
cautiously optimistic i would say is
it is my mood in the mood of the nation
right now looking ahead to monday
but the labour party says this is
reckless and and to be fair there is
concern andrew isn't there about the
the besa variant and the gamma variant
which we don't think the vaccine is as
effective
effective against and which you know
pretty much are just not in this country
at the moment well it's
it's going to open a pathway for them
isn't it
well look i think these vaccines have
proved remarkably resilient steve and
uh i think i think kierstama has called
this one wrong
actually uh he said reckless he said we
would be going soaring up to a hundred
thousand infections a day he's gone
rather quiet on that now
it was a line which all the shadow
ministers were parroting
i'm i'm not saying that he wanted it to
go horribly wrong
but he banked on it going wrong and now
the figures are going
the other way so uh be interesting to
see if labor
welcome that if they start to say uh
that's
it because it is great news the
infections are falling
far quicker than even the most not the
evening even some of the more optimistic
uh scientists suggested and i think
we've got to have confidence in this
vaccine
the astrozenica vaccine has been
brilliant so as the fisa vaccine
and um the delta varian it's got the
better of the delta variant
the kent variant and i think we should
be pretty confident
uh and i think rachel's right too there
was a spike after the euros the football
uh tens of thousands of people coming to
britain
lots of people coming into wembley for
the matches the football fans i saw
in leicester square not only were they
not wearing mars most of them weren't
wearing shirts either
as they were swilling beer and wine out
of bottles from 10 in the morning
so there was always going to be a spike
but the really important thing is
there hasn't been a substantial or even
disturbing increase
in the number of deaths in our hospitals
the number of admissions to hospitals
have gone up
but not dramatically okay when it comes
rachel to you know certainly letting
travelers from the united states in
the telegraph looking you know we want
tip for tad on this if
if we're letting the the americans in
here we wouldn't be
able to head over there are we likely to
make any progress
it's that special relationship again
isn't it we let u.s
travelers uh into into britain without
quarantining
as long as they're double backs can we
can we expect reciprocal rights in
return
not yet i think the this isn't
particularly surprising
uh as is often pointed out in
discussions about say trade negotiations
the u.s a much larger and more powerful
and influential country
sadly than britain though britain is
also very influential just not quite on
the level of being able to
to bargain with the us in in quite that
way and i think there's a
an awful lot on joe biden's plate at the
moment uh handling the pandemic
is going to be the the core feature
of certainly his his his first year in
office uh
and potentially his entire presidency
he's not going to
risk that just because officials in
britain are saying we're letting your
guys in
could you let us in too i think it's
more surprising
uh not not yet getting reciprocal rights
from
from the eu just because of the the
volume of travel is it is higher there
i'm sure this will happen in time and it
does take one country
leading the way and saying we trust your
vaccines
and therefore we we trust your
government and
that globalized system and and freedom
of of travel
that the the globalized liberal economy
was based on
pre-covered um but i think i think us
making a stand and saying that that we
we accept that is important expecting
america to
agree to it just because we've said that
we'll take their travelers
possibly a little bit naive directing
andrew
yeah there's talk that they might not uh
change the rules until september
and funny thing was you know just before
jason when they all came
to cornwall and we saw brick cornwall at
its best showcase
there was speculation even then that
there could be an announcement between
britain and the united states about
reopening the airways uh that really
didn't happen
and rachel's right biden's not going to
budge uh
he saw how much damage the uh
the response of of um trump to covid
calls to his presidency i don't think
biden would even be the president of the
united states now
if trump had got a grip i've tried of
i've covered much sooner much earlier
and hadn't downplayed
and ridiculed it and even suggested at
one point didn't he that you should
inject yourself with um bleach to try
and rid yourself of it uh so
he's going to be ultra cautious they've
had a pretty good vaccination roller in
the united states but of course
every state is different and every state
has different rules so
i think if you want to go on holiday to
san francisco
uh steve or miami beach if that's your
bag you're gonna have to wait at least
the middle of september
miami beach only if i can wear a a full
body suit i think at my
channel um look let's have a look at the
front of the times
where i mean because it's interesting
isn't it in all of this
that obviously there is a clear appetite
for for these changes for business and
indeed from
from a lot of members of the public but
the scientists still
pretty concerned i mean do we call i
mean you called them sort of
doom mongers earlier on andrew but they
i mean they are following the science
they are trying to be sensible in all of
this
well it depends which scientist you
listen to that's always the point you
get it's like anything else isn't it you
get six scientists in a room they can
all have completely different views
uh we heard professor lockdown on the
today program
was it yesterday uh uh almost blithely
saying that
actually it looked now like kobe would
be gone or could be
in full retreat by october not even
acknowledging the fact he'd been
predicting just a few weeks ago
we'd be having up to 200 000 cases a day
so
and there's a lot of um i'm not saying
eating humble pie
they all make their predictions as best
they can on the modeling they can
but i think when johnson took that boris
johnson took that decision
to um remove those last lot of
restrictions
i suspect there was even some opposition
from within sage
and i and i'm not even sure witty and
valence the two
uh the two chuckle brothers as we like
to call them the chief scientific
scientific officer chief medical officer
were 100 ultimately i think it was a
political decision
and i think it was right it was a
political decision in the end because
the economy
the economy we cannot neglect the
economy any longer
yeah i mean it's interesting though
rachel isn't it because i mean andrew's
point may be
absolutely valid i'm sure the chancellor
would probably be thinking that but
you know we've been told from the outset
we're going to follow the science well
it seems like we are diverging from that
now
i don't think that's necessarily the
case as andrew said the sciences
is mixed and the fact is that
with the vaccine roll out the scientists
just don't know how the modeling is
going to play out
because there is so much unknown
particularly the rates of transmission
for people who are who are double
vaccinated and i think you've got to
balance the wanting to keep the
restrictions
in order to reduce transmission with
wanting to
maximize vaccine take up and one of the
ways that you
eliminate vaccine hesitancy is by saying
to people this actually
works and this is the thing if you do
this your life and the life of everyone
you love and the life of one in the
country
can go back to normal we had this weird
system
for a couple of months where the
government was very much encouraging
people to get the vaccine
but also being uh very cautious about
the benefits of the vaccine and
and there have been concerns that that
has fueled a certain amount of vaccine
hesitancy
why would i take something which the
government is telling me might not have
any
impact so i think you've got to balance
those two things and the government
is trying to do that i think it's also
worth noting that while we're talking
lots about how we're opening up the
economy and we're letting travelers in
and uh and how this is really good for
business
it's still another over two weeks 16th
of august
until the rules are changing and double
vaccinated people
uh who are pinged or who come into
contact with somebody who test positive
won't have to isolate anymore after that
point lots of other countries aren't
doing that lots of other countries are
saying if you're double vaccinated
you don't have to isolate so britain
actually is still being quite cautious
in that regard certain restrictions
easing other restrictions saying
it's a balance and i think following the
science at this point means looking at
the data very carefully
and making decisions based on that
because we just don't know
okay lovely thank you both don't go
anywhere because in just a couple of
minutes we've got more papers including
a focus on that success for team gb
including charlotte de jardins
record medal hall back in a minute
this is the press preview and we're
going through the papers with andrew
pierce
and rachel cunliffe so let's turn our
attention to
the olympics we've got something to
celebrate at last and by heck do we need
it
andrew in the mail a lot of focus on
uh charlotte du jardin her
record-breaking
medal hall she's um
what a performer she is now the most
successful female british olympian in
history she got bronze
in the individual dressage today uh
having got bronze in the
team yesterday having won golds before
she's remarkable i mean dressage is
mind-bogglingly mind-boggling to me i
don't know how on earth
anybody can exert such control over
horse but she does it
she's fantastic she's very humble and
she said she feels incredibly humble to
have
pinched that record because the it was
previously held by the woman who's the
head of uk
sport uh who was a rower katherine
granger
uh and uh and she was the first to
congratulate her so it's a terrific
achievement for her
and you know these olympics coming so
soon after the euros where
even though we lost in the end on
penalties of course we lost on penalties
we always do
uh i think they cheered everybody up
after the horrors
of lockdown and the olympics i was a bit
skeptical whether people would get
swept up in the in in in in the
excitement
and i think that people have been
including me steve and as you know
what i know about sport you can write on
the back of a postage stamp
stamp that's been shrunk in the rain
yeah you don't need to know a lot
sometimes
to enjoy it though dear i have to say uh
rachel i mean there's a lot of focus
we've been reporting on tonight the fact
that
you know we've got more women and the
men in team gb for the first time ever
and the women are leading from the front
absolutely it's wonderful to see
and i in terms of getting into the
olympics what i love about the olympics
is
you you start watching a sport that
you've never really considered before
and within five minutes you're really
into it and you understand the scoring
so i i watched the the dressage
or horse ballet as i like to call it um
and
charlotte uh incredible the controls she
had over the horse
this horse is crossing sideways the the
hooves are coming up and crossing over
how can you do that with it it's such a
magical sport to watch
but again one that outside of the the
four-year cycles of the olympics
you you very rarely see um and so i
think it's
that's what i love about discovering new
sports uh becoming an armchair expert in
something
in just a couple of minutes and then
obviously the excitement as those
records do
do get broken which is always wonderful
to see yeah well we were tight for time
but we've got to look at the swimmers as
well andrew because i mean
they have been outstanding they don't
they've controlled the pool they've
dominated it in the way that we do
so well at cycling and rowing but in in
the team gb in the pool another gold
medal today in the relay the 200 meter
freestyle relay
unbelievable i mean they won it by
almost half a pole extraordinary and the
18 year old who ran
who swam the third leg 18 years old uh
and his parents when we got into
lockdown bought him like a
five foot deep paddling ball so he could
train in the garden
and his mum who's a teacher getting up
at three o'clock every morning to drive
him to
train in a swimming pool she'd sleep in
the car bring him back then she'd go to
work in a classroom
the parents of these athletes deserve
gold medals too
yeah i mean it is a family success in
all of this we i mean just highlights
that the shame that they're not there to
to witness their children do so well
right so sad yeah and you you saw that
as well with
uh tom daley's win and in the interview
with
his his mother and his husband and his
his son
all the way over in in canada via skype
obviously
in normal times it would have been there
in the stadium so it's definitely got a
different vibe this olympics but that
doesn't take away from the
the celebration especially when it's
it's it's unexpected like in swimming
where
we're not used to doing so well or like
the the women's gymnastics who
the women's gymnastics team the gbt
managed to get a bronze medal which i
don't think anyone was expecting
so that was a very exciting moment as
well those moments of unexpected glory
yeah it's lovely we need something to
smile about they're certainly delivering
on that
lovely thank you both